بعد يومين فقط من اثاره رئيس الاركان
الاسرائيليه لاحتمال تحرك ضد ايران بسبب
برنامجها النووي طهران تكشف النقاب عن
اقوى صواريخها البالسيه ويصل يصل مدى هذا
الصاروخ الى الفيكومتر لا يمكن رصده او
اعتراضه لكن وان لم تقل انه تهديد
لاسرائيل لكن الالفي كيلومتر مدى الصاروخ
هي المسافه من ايران الى عمق اسرائيل
الصاروخ البالست الايراني كما نشاهده هنا
خرم شهر تحت اسم خيبر يمتلك راسا حربيا
وزنه 1500 كيلو جرام هذه الرساله مشاهدينا
موجهه للعدو يقول هنا وزير الدفاع
الايراني محمد رضا اشتياني كي يعلم بان
بلاده ستدافع عن نفسها وانجازاتها لاسيما
النوويه منها البرنامج الصاروخ الايراني
وتحديدا البالست طورته طهران على مر
السنوات الم اضيه والاسلحه هنا اي اسلحه
الطهران قادره على الوصول الى اسرائيل
والقواعد الامريكيه في المنطقه وفق
بياناتها رغم طبعا معارضه الولايات
المتحده وقلق الدول الاوروبيه التي تعثرت
كافه جهودها منذ سبتمبر الماضي لاحياء
اتفاق طهران النووي المبرم عام 2015
الصاروخ خيبر الارادي بالصين من جيل خرم
شهر 4 يصل مداه الى 2000 كيلومتر يمتلك
راسا حربيا وزنه 1500 كيلو جرام عند اصابه
الهدف يعطل الانظمه الدفاعيه المضاده لذا
لا يمكن رصده واعتراضه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات